نواه مشاهدينا بالخبر العاجل الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل ضابط برتبه نقيب في
معارك شماليه قطاع
غزه معنا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس اذا هناك تجدد للقصف العنيف
ولن نرى ذلك في افق الصوره خلفك ما الوضع
لديك بالفعل مياده وقبل لحظات قليله اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل ضابط برو بت نقيب
وهو في خدمه الاحتياط قتل في معارك شمال
قطاع غزه في الساعات ال 24 الماضيه واعلن
عن مقتله قبل لحظات قليله وبذلك يرتفع عدد
الجنود الذين قتلوا منذ انتهاء هذه الهدنه
في مطلع هذا الشهر الى 100 وجندي واحد
والى اكثر من 170 جنديا منذ بدايه
العمليات البريه في ال 26 من اكتوبر
الماضي ومن الواضح بان المعارك مازالت على
اشدها هنا في المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه
محاور عديده حقيقه مشتعله هذا النهار
وكانها في الايام الاولى للعمليات البريه
كل المنطقه الان هنالك كما يبدو اطلاق
لصواريخ باتجاه
منطقه ناح
العوز يبدو كذلك هنالك دفعه صاروخيه تنطلق
من المواقع التي تتعرض للاستهداف من جانب
ال الجيش الاسرائيلي على الاقل قذيفتين
صاروخيتين اطلق من هذه المواقع الشماليه
نستطيع ان نراها يبدو انها انطلقت من
منطقه جباليا المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه
وواضح بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما زالت
لها لديها القدره على اطلاق هذه الدفعات
الصاروخيه باتجاه منطقه غلاف غزه في مواقع
اي اي مختلفه في القطاع اي تحديدا المناطق
الشماليه لكن ايضا المناطق الجنوبيه تشهد
اطلاقا للصواريخ بين الحين والاخر تمتد
احيانا اخرى الى مدينه عسقلان والى ابعد
من ذلك كما راينا في الايام الماضيه اذا
ضربات صاروخيه ايضا من جانب المقاومه في
خضم هذه المعركه المشتعله الان في كل
المناطق الشماليه ل في قطاع غزه بيت لاهيه
بيت حنون مشتعله جباليا البلد والمخيم
مشتعله وكذلك حي التفاح في المناطق
الشماليه لمدينه غزه ايضا هذا الحي مشتعل
حيث قال الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه وسع من
عملياته العسكريه في هذا الحي في الايام
الماضيه ولا يبدو ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
قادر على حسم هذه المعركه حتى هنا في
المناطق الشماليه الجيش الاسرائيلي كما هو
معلوم في بدايه هذا الشهر وعندما انهارت
الهدنه او انتهت الهدنه كان يتحدث عن ايام
معدوده ويحسم فيها هذه المعركه في المناطق
الشماليه وهذا ما كان يروجه حتى المحللون
العسكريون في اسرائيل وقالوا بان المساله
هي مساله ايام وينتهي الامر في المناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه وبعدها يتفرغ الجيش
الاسرائيلي ل العمل العسكري في المنطقه
الجنوبيه لكن واضح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
بعيد كل البعد عن حسم المعركه هنا في
المنطقه الشماليه ومن الواضح بانه يقود
حرب استنزاف هذا ما يقراه ايضا كثير من
المحللين العسكريين وما يقراه كثير من
الضباط والقيادات الامنيه العليا في
اسرائيل سابقا هم يقولون بان اسرائيل يبدو
انها تغوص في بح في وحل قطاع غزه ياتون
على نموذج جنوب لبنان في ثمانينيات
وتسعينيات القرن الماضي يقولون بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم يحق يحقق صوره انتصار وربما
حقق انجازات تكتيكيه هنا او او هناك لكنه
لم يراكم حتى الى انجاز استراتيجي واحد
يحسم فيه المعركه اذا المعركه على اشدها
هنا في المناطق الشماليه واضح بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم ينهي هذه المعركه وواضح بان
الانفاق الهجوميه هي المعضله ال كاداء في
وجه الجيش الاسرائيلي الانفاق الهجوميه هي
التي تسدد هذه الضربات لجيش اسرائيل ومن
خلالها تنطلق كما يبدو معظم العمليات ضد
الجيش في هذه المناطق المناطق الجنوبيه ما
زالت ايضا تشهد قتالا شرسا تحديدا في
منطقه خانيونس والدليل على ذلك هو الزج
بلواء سابع للمشاركه في العمليات القتاليه
هناك كما اعلنت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
صباح هذا اليوم اذا سبعه الويه تعمل في
منطقه خان يونس وحدها ونحن نتحدث عن اعداد
كبيره اذا من الجنود الاسرائيليين بمشاركه
الف فرقه رقم 98 وكتائب متعدده من
المدرعات وفرق الهندسه التي تعمل في منطقه
خان يونس يحاولون تطويق المدينه التي
يعتبرونها مركز ثقل كبير بالنسبه لقيادات
حركه حماس اسمح لي الياس ان نوه بالعواجيز
الماليه الاسرائيلي يقول نحترم الولايات
المتحده ورئيسها لكننا لن نترك مصيرنا
ابدا في ايدي الاجانب وكان وزير الدفاع
الامريكي قد قال انه ناقش مع نظيره
الاسرائيلي العمليات في غزه والتهديدات
التي يت عرض لها الامن الاقليمي فيما
يتعلق بما اشرت اليه رياس من معركه
استنزاف الان ايضا يعلن الجانب الاسرائيلي
انه رفد قواته في خانيونس تحديدا بلواء
سابع هذا يؤشر الى امتداد هذه العمليه
وطول مدها
اذا بالفعل والجيش الاسرائيلي يريد ان
يحقق تقدما في المنطقه الجنوبيه على
اعتبار انها ت تشكل مركز ثقل كبير بالنسبه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه وتحديدا
لقيادتها العليا السياسيه والعسكريه هم
يحاولون الان تكثيف هذا النشاط العسكري في
منطقه خانيونس علهم يتمكنون من حسم
المعركه لصالحهم هناك لكن واضح انهم فشلوا
حتى الان في حسمها في المناطق الجنوبيه و
في الشماليه وواضح بان المعركه في المنطقه
الجنوبيه سوف تكون ايه اشد واقوى و واعنف
والجيش الاسرائيلي يحاول حقيقه الوصول الى
القيادات العليا يحاول العمل في الانفاق
تحت الارضيه وهذا ما يؤكد عليه الجيش
الاسرائيلي حتى في بياناته هم يحاولون
الوصول الى مناطق يعتقدون ان يحيى السنوار
ومروان عيسى ومحمد الضيف وغيرهم من
القيادات العسكريه البارزه موجودون هناك
في هذه الانفاق ويقولون بان ربما كثير
كثير من الاسرى الاسرائيليين موجودين ايضا
حولهم لذلك هم يحاولون الوصول والعمل تحت
الانفاق تحديدا في منطقه خانيونس وبذلك هم
كثفوا النشاط العسكري في الايام الماضيه
كما تقول بياناتهم على الاقل والاعلان هذا
الصباح في اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي بانهم
دفعوا وزجوا بلواء سابع الى تلك المنطقه
هذا يعني بان الجيش الاسرائيلي سوف يعمل
كما يبدو في الساعات القادمه وفي الايام
القادمه على تكثيف عمليه ه العسكريه هناك
في محاوله ربما لايجاد صوره نصر هنا يعني
حتى الان الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يعرض على
المجتمع الاسرائيلي اي صوره نصر لم يحقق
اي صوره نصر حقيقيه يمكن ان يقول بانه اي
يعني انجز فيها امرا عسكريا كبيرا على
العكس من ذلك تماما واضح بانه يخوض حرب
استنزاف في كل محاور القتال في شمال في
وسط قطاع غزه في جنوب قطاع غزه لذلك هم
يحاولون ان يصوروا بان امكانيه وصولهم
للقيادات العليا لقيادات الصف الاول في
حركه حماس قد يشكل او يعطيهم صوره انتصار
بامكانهم من خلالها ان يعرضوها على
المجتمع الاسرائيلي وربما بعدها محاوله
الانتقال الى ما يسمونها المرحله الثالثه
في العمليات ال العسكريه وهي الخروج من
المناطق الماهوله واعاده الانتشار ربما
على اطرافها سواء كان ذلك في المناطق
الشماليه او في المناطق الوسطى على الاقل
في المرحله الاولى هذا ما كان يلمح اليه
بالامس حقيقه وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يواف
جلنت الذي كان في جوله تفقديه هنا في احدى
وحدات الجيش الاسرائيلي في منطقه غلاف غزه
وتحدث عن هذه المساله وواضح حتى ان في
كلامه وفي كلام الجيش الاسرائيلي في
الايام الماضيه هنالك قناعه بانه لن يمكن
تحطيم حركه حماس كليا كما كان الهدف
الرئيسي المعلن في بدايه هذه الحرب هم
يقولون بانه لن يمكننا ان نصل الى اخر
خليه في حركه حماس ولن يمكننا ربما القضاء
على حركه حماس كليا وان هذا سوف يتطلب
شهورا وبدا يوف جلان بالامس يتحدث عندما
التقى بالجنود على ان هذه العمليه قد
تستمر شهورا كثيره من اجل الوصول الى قاده
حركه حماس او القضاء على كل الخلايا وان
اسرائيل سوف تنطلق في خضم ذلك الى مراحل
اخرى من عمليات القتال اشكرك حتى اللحظه
من غلاف غزه مراسل الجز الياس كرم